i have a quick question
are you aware of any government whether
it's our own having possession of
an alien body
are you asking me any
jim or tom
i'm not going to comment on them yeah
i'm not you know i think there's no way
for us to be aware i mean we all hear
the stories we all talk about it online
or read about it online
um you know we're that's one of the
reasons why we're trying to figure out
about the material that we got so we
have material from a purported crash in
the late 40s we don't really have a
chain of title all the way back then we
do for like 20 years or something we
know there's a lot of anomalies about
the way it's engineered we have some
theories of what it can do there's been
a lot of studies on it the government's
very interested in this piece but if
that piece ended up being real then it's
like well what else was it a part of and
who was piloting this thing was it a
drone was it not i think it kind of
it
gets us to ask a lot of questions um
i have you know i'm i'm under the
thinking that you know if there's things
that have been around here for thousands
of years then there's absolutely the
potential for some of these stories to
be real the problem is is like
you're not going to get anybody to come
out
and just say that um
so easily i i think that there's steps
to this you know i look at the task
force report and i look at what's going
on now and
and if i
if there was such a thing like bodies or
craft or whatever
um
and they're so advanced and they're
somehow influencing
the you know mankind and the way we are
engineered to evolve or something crazy
i mean because i look at us now it's
like first we we got into the biology of
our bodies and then we got deeper and we
got into like you know um dna and what
that's doing and every time we master
parts of the body and parts of you know
the world we see and touch and feel like
what's the next thing well i think the
next thing is going to be discovering
consciousness and then we're going to go
how do we manipulate consciousness and
how do we capture it and how do we